all right so in Gaza Gaza is a spiritual
training okay so I'm practicing release
I feel my mind my ego Tri part mind
start to dominate I got to let go there
I got to release
okay and the metric
is fluidity
spontaneity okay so as you go and I go
here that right there you see that is
Jam I don't have fluidity I don't have
spontaneity I don't have a tus I don't
have a Reconciliation of and Y I'm just
going to try to push that down that
would be a fail okay so let's say let's
say we'll do that again so instead of
I'm like I could feel that you see like
I know don't push on
it so I felt like jamm okay look you see
how smooth I went around okay
that would be where you're actually
doing G was it do you do you understand
do you get what I'm saying okay so same
thing like oh look it's jammed it's only
jammed because I stayed
here not J
see
oh let's say he he stuffs that leg there
get your leg there see okay again
they're like oh oh no not
Jam so you do that same
thing he stuffed that leg you see not
J smooth
action same thing
here
and here not
ja you you would never know that I had
to release that that point okay so try
that let's
go so even the desire to throw
okay
better even the the rejection of a
technique do you see is not what we
[Music]
want notice how your hand is on the
other side of his head this the m is too
close do you
see you're forcing that
technique doesn't fit
[Music]
there better
okay so then and then it's very similar
like we it's hard to tell for us maybe I
I think we can but you're like there's a
difference between picking a technique
and then letting a technique happen so
if we now change it and you're going to
do two elbow sleeve
grabs that's your that's what you're
doing okay so you stay the nogget here
we go grab each elbow sleeve go go
come
on and so you you you could see what did
you see
happen was it is it as smooth as the
last one for katatori no
right because I don't I don't normally
practice that right I don't normally
practice this feeling here as I'm
going but it's the same
[Music]
feeling
for
change it to
[Music]
whatever
for
hey
[Music]
fres
remember it's whatever we're not doing
the sleeve anymore it's
whatever again not C
you find his Center move his
Center
better
keep on
moving don't expose your
back
no need to go
faster
[Music]
that's thinking more
feeling
feeling move keep it
going so when when you when you get told
like composite hoodie you see and then
you get told
whatever the ego Tri party mind goes
well that's totally different but to the
god mind there is no there there is no
whatever and then in vice versa there is
no top so like for
example uh as I get myself in that state
whatever right you'll see that I kind of
reach I reach for you right and so if
you pay attention I'll almost always
reach for you you see and then it
generates that the it that the the
tonden communion and then I just work
that okay so I as we're moving I'll
always reach you
see
I reach it's the same exact feeling to
meate
[Music]
reach devate
reach
[Music]
deviate
Le
[Music]
touou
touch so even though that looks totally
weird to me it feels the
same looks weird feels the same
right
okay all right play with that
deviate
reach ADH here Ikea at the to and then
you just move
that
okay deviate
feeling and one of the kazushi
patterns front inward back
outward deviate
feeling kazushi pattern x
[Music]
pattern deviate reach connection feeling
and kazushi
pattern
[Music]
again no no twisting and turning you're
going to go to one of the kazushi
patterns front inward back
outward deviate reach connection
feeling do it
again deviate
[Music]
reach
feeling you got to get off the line
let's go that's enough get in
there and make something
happen
you're deviate reach
connection keep the
[Music]
feeling
better he all right so what I what I
mean is I deviate there's there's the
feeling I want and then I'm going
to you can see that I have that okay it
depends what heat does Okay so so some
people are like whoa okay cool then I'll
take it you
see some people you get there and he's
like coming back into me you see okay
cool we'll go this way I still have my
keto principles that path release
resistance that's the one you want to
take okay so I I do my thing okay
there's the connection right I'll show
you what happened
there see if I can so he's come around
this way right and normally I'd go
here but he turned so sharp so sharp
this way so it came this
way I I won't Force the the one of
thetion poers where is his body going
keep it going in from where he's is to
where he's going to one of the kazushi
patterns okay and then the way that I
mean you could do that from the very
beginning right so look
see but I like to play in in my gu I
play with it I feel what he's
doing do you get what I'm saying
so um play a little bit but the
principle is going to be the same
don't you know your destination front in
rukushi back out
rushi but you have to um not make
radical turns and reversals in his
energy as you get him there so you let
him decide which one of those he's going
to do I don't pick it okay I just stay
in the
relationship okay all right try again a
critique here okay so you guys are
getting a lot of
a in different variation right
here
okay uh
is kind of gaming it because we we say
go slow that's a lot of energy that
we've be coming at you okay so if you
pay attention even like I like to do
this one right I like to do that one
okay but it's not that I'm pulling you
back if you pay
attention so his energy we'll start from
the
T his energy is going that way you see
but there's a small turn back that way
you see um so
[Music]
even you can't pull backwards what's
going
backwards and you can't uh shove shove
the other way what's coming forward you
can't do that you got to harmonize Y and
Y okay so if uh if I'm rocking this one
you see I don't go yeah got it you
you'll you'll see that I'll I'll kind of
fade right here you see I always fade so
it doesn't matter here this short there
can you feel that
so right now I would do it there but
same thing when I go here I don't go
boom and I shove them backwards that way
you'll see boom I'll hit you
see to kind of get that turn going right
boom po there
makes head you
see Asos to just pushing your
body right or if you don't if you don't
want to hit him when you're here then
you come this way Bo and
there's again
okay we not
here the first one is Boom here
okay does that make sense you can't just
shove things
backwards okay so let's say you're doing
s no G in this slow pace right but
you'll see
circle circle
circle or change your
weapon see always reconciling the yin
and yang
without gaming what we're already gaming
try to